petite anecdote on m'a offert un couteau
suisse il n'ya pas longtemps un vrai
regardez et devinez quoi c'est un super
cadeau
il ya un peu plus de deux ans que nous
étions tous jeune et innocent et quand
une bonne partie d'entre vous n'avez pas
encore quelle je suis encore on avait
fait une vidéo suite à là à ma
découverte des toujours en retard comme
d'hab des caméras aux portes des deux
rebelles caméra j'avais adoré cette
découverte parce que ça donne naissance
à des vidéos en tout genre qui sont
assez hilarante à j'adore regarder des
gens filmés à leur insu à je suis
malsain comme mec désabonner ou [ __ ]
j'en ai mis une pour de vrai sur mon
palier sauf que chez en immeuble au
dernier étage donc bye bye il se passe
pas grand chose je vais être honnête
avec vous un achat un peu peut-être
abusif en plus des libraires dans mon
quartier sont trop sympa malade j'ai
jamais eu de problème achats inutiles
après ils sont peut-être un pacte social
en mai la pression ils savent qu'elle
est là mais savent pas qu'elle a plus de
batterie aujourd'hui c'est la suite de
cette vidéo d'il ya deux ans et demi on
va voir ce qui s'est passé depuis deux
ans dans l'oeil de ces caméras va
découvrir ça ensemble et encore une fois
généralement c'est cool parce que c'est
des gens qui font des petites bêtises
qui font un peu les zozos les zouaves et
qui ne savent pas qu'ils aient traces
vidéo de leur eau abris et ça ça me
régale bref on est une des rebelles
caméra qui envoie un message
personnalisé quand elle détecte
quelqu'un quelqu'un est venu toquer à
notre porte quelques jours et il n'a pas
aimé non mais c'est quand tu as une
maison c'est ouf ces caméras les gars je
serai tout le temps les yeux rivés
dessus pour de vrai il vient prendre du
linge sale ou quoi il vient récupérer
leur soldat ce que c'est vrai
pas mal non frérot lui compter sur toi
pour récupérer le linge sale et laver
non tu déconne mais qui tout ça pour un
petit message café qui fait tout le
monde le 31 octobre dernier un livreur
domino's pizza m'a demandé si j'avais
des instructions spécifiques je lui ai
dit de mettre la pizza sur la table de
taper la porte trois fois de faire un
effet inverse la caméra et partir en
courant il a tout donné oh non j'adore
les vidéos livres et un million mais
j'ai fait une découverte le monde n'est
pas si pur innocent que vous le croyez
regardons en avant il pose la pizza
l'étape 3 faux avec son pied il
ferraille five et part en courant il est
trop mignon je me commander une pizza
domino's tient aux fauves n'est tombé
dans le piège et j'ai découvert hélas je
ne préférais ne jamais le savoir qu'en
fait c'est des techniques marketing des
entreprises pour montrer que le livreur
ils sont trop mignons et tout fait pour
donner envie aux gens de commander
chesaux tout simplement c'est bon alors
je n'ai pas qu'elles le sont toutes en
tout cas il ya une énorme partie d'entre
elles qui le sont et je me suis fait
berner voilà je suis dégoûté bon j'ai
reçu un appel me disant que ma voiture
avait eu un accident alors qu'elle se
trouvait devant chez moi heureusement la
caméra des voisins a tout vu
[Musique]
0 c'est impossible fait un effort [ __ ]
achètent des rollers et arrête de
conduire ça m'est arrivé cela m'est
arrivé je me suis pris 3 4 jours au ski
natsuki saut dans la neige - qui rigole
un peu de froid nous je déteste ça
d'accord je reste dans ma chambre quatre
jours tout se passe bien lorsque la
réception m'appelle haut que se
passe-t-il du champagne gratuit le mec
me dit monsieur j'ai une bonne et une
mauvaise nouvelle bon bah là on commence
par la mauvaise comme ça on finit sur un
truc bien et au téléphone on me dit
voilà le voiturier il a il a vu mais
votre voiture les gars ma première
voiture la bonne nouvelle du coup
écoutez bien cette réponse il fait beau
demain
fin du coup de fil
bref ça m'arrive est ce pas très
agréable après les assurances tout
quarante ans j'ai eu donc ça va mais
façon moi je rejoins est une trottinette
dans très peu de temps maring capture
toujours les meilleurs moments de ma vie
[Musique]
oui sans son chien
mérite et c'est mérité fais tu sors en
short claquettes chaussettes mais arrête
arrête ton déc moi aussi je sui team été
mais c'est bon un moment imaginé vidéo
gag vous sonnez vidéo gag
s'il y avait eu les deux rebelles caméra
tout leur contenu se remettait ça mon
voisin m'a envoyé ce truc de sa caméra
après que mes colis était délivré à sa
maison au lieu de la mienne alors à la
maison il est en train de prendre
écoulée qui vient de livrer pour les
remettre dans son camion pour les amener
à la bonne maison je crois qu'il est
furax
attend la vidéo est donc je sens qu'il
va escalader c'est dans ces émotions là
n'ont donc pas aux colis temps prend pas
aux colis
car ben
non la taille des colis versus comment
ils ont l'air léger amazon il faut
arrêter de livrer des cartes sd dans des
colis de 1 mètre on a compris vous avez
plein de cartons pleins de rembourrage
maintenant ça suffit aujourd'hui j'étais
heureux d'avoir des caméras chez moi
one piece et passe sous les portes aux
le bâtard
[Musique]
quoi mauvaise idée dans
i look rock se bat à il va le prendre
non il va le prendre mais calero
one
à 10 sur 10 écoutez moins bien si
j'étais à sa place je serais resté
bloqué à l'étape une c'est à dire les
escaliers le serpent aurait pu
littéralement me tuer juste en restant à
la sortie des escaliers et en me disant
ah bah il ya un serpent une énorme
araignée dans la maison c'est un truc
genre méga basique pour plein de gens
moi c'est une situation j'en sais si
j'appelle macron gelé pris la main dans
le sac en train de me voler mon vélo
à la peste
non
quoi l aah quitte
c'est tout mais c'est un voleur level
c'est la première partie d'une pub mafia
city le truc
personnes à l'aref j'étais chez moi
toute la semaine sauf pendant une heure
et c'est l'heure où j'ai raté edward aux
mains d'argent
[Musique]
il doit les oreilles
aux non il est trop mignon
que quelqu'un veuille ou
[Musique]
non il fut son
son implication dans le rôle c'est trop
touchant quoi il veut trop faire plaisir
ça se voit il est trop adorable brasse
hommes d affaires et rentrer aujourd'hui
n'est pas ton jours en corse est le même
c'est la suite de la tournée du gars de
thales
[Musique]
faith blesse c'est pas drôle du tout
quoi faudrait moi je rigole trop bas
les gars une petite pensée à tous les
livreurs qui font un travail extrêmement
stressant et dur la moitié du temps ils
ont pas la bonne adresse l'autre moitié
les gens leur parle mal au téléphone
voilà gros courage et big up à tous les
livres ma lumière a ruiné l'entraînement
des escalades de ce mec la nuit dernière
en tellement mignon heureusement je lis
pas dans un pays où il ya des rats cool
en fait j arrêterai pas les nourrir et y
aurait des armées de raku devant ma
maison et après genre deux ans serait
plus ma maison serait leur maison et
c'est moi qui te crée chez eux c'est des
animaux les gars oublions pas qu'ils
sont là pour prendre le dessus s'il faut
mais bon je suis à paris je veux ma
portière pigeon mon frérot bah tiens
tiens dont ok c'est un mec installer une
caméra devant un bac de graines pour
filmer les oiseaux qui viennent d'en
prendre et la juge genre un pigeon qui
est venu et qui a tout gâché comme d'hab
c'est toujours pareil
non mais mais qu est-ce qu il ne serait
ce qu'une personne qui aime de fous les
pigeons sur la planète on attend en
france on a un truc pas mal dans les
jardins les hérissons adorable un
hérisson en vrai mais bon ça vaut par
raccoon [ __ ] bon bah c'est arrivé
encore un mais quittons
avec big voix grave ça va craquer ça va
tomber c'est les fréquences de sa voix
ça va casser le
genre tu restes assis par terre et tu
reste aussi capt'ain j'adore les gens de
chez lui comme ça au et squeeze au
saxophone vous savez que vous et moi on
vit une belle histoire d'amour depuis un
bon moment maintenant regardez la vidéo
qui suit à le nombre de gens en train de
regarder la vidéo baisse c'est bizarre
je vais vous dire un truc pour te fixes
ragueneau fob depuis qu'on a fait la
vidéo avec seb dans laquelle on a eu une
mygale sûr nous ça a complètement changé
ma vision et ma perception des araignées
georges fut beaucoup plus apaisées c'est
bizarre hein mais comme quoi quand le
livreur ups sonne à la porte et voit le
signe ne sonnait pas mes enfants font la
sieste
[Musique]
au noise bas ils sont veut trop en même
temps tu n'as pas envie d'affronter le
regard d'une mère qui a précisé mes
enfants pour la sieste ce départ qui
peut lui en vouloir c'est pire que ce
serait à mes deux fois quand livre un
colis au notre caméra a détecté un
visage
bois
mais n'ont pas de panique regardez si
cette maison elle a simplement une tête
de visage et vous savez ce que c'est on
a vu en vidéo il ya deux trois ans je me
souviens encore c'est de l'appareil
dolly parra et idole y pari d'owlient oh
[ __ ] encore footage qui fait peur ça
par contre c'est relou les footage comme
ça là
haut ça se passe là quoi
mon
waouh
c'est l'ancien propriétaire de la maison
il est mort de vieillesse dans le
fauteuil dans le salon il avait pour
habitude d'aller à 3h05 sur la terrasse
ionides club pas du tout mon frigo c'est
un sac plastique regardez apparemment il
ya beaucoup de vent et on voit wiki ce
truc-là bouge et c'est un sac plastique
qui volent dans le doute moi je déménage
juste dans le doute ou quelqu'un a vu ça
sur sa caméra de sécurité dans mon pays
non mais arrêtez là allez pourquoi et
d'un puits la mine stricte paranormaux
ça suffit
aussi tout ce que je déteste les films
d'horreur asiatiques pour moi sont de
très loin les pires parce qu'il ya tout
le temps ça des gens à quatre pattes d
articuler qui marche très très vite vers
toi mandarine et je déteste ça mec j'ai
l'explication il ya des personnes qui
ont un handicap ou leur rotule sont
inversés ce qui fait qu'elles sont
obligées de marcher à quatre pattes et
je pense que là c'est ce qu'on voit
voilà c'est beaucoup moins drôle hein
que de croire que c'est un démon
asiatiques mais j'ai bien calmé la hache
et nick et l'ambiance mon cri quand j'ai
réalisé que j'étais enfermée devant ma
maison sans les clés montcoal rock a vu
ça sur la caméra emma direct appelé pour
se [ __ ] de ma gueule c'est ça bien ce
qu'on aime n'oubliez pas de vous mettre
un colloque avec vos amis pour se moquer
d'eux encore et encore
[Musique]
au
père fouras qu'elle est l'énigme je suis
passer pour un con dès l'instant même où
j'ai installé ma caméra
[Musique]
vous l'avez vu son regard aux moments
ici c'est pas encore que sa chute va
être un moment qui restera entre lui et
son chien si ça va être un truc vue par
des millions de gens des milieux d'un
coup du partout sur terre qui vont tout
de sa gueule et la malle attendez on
peut pas avérée la malle
messieurs dames c'est la fin de cette
vidéo dans lequel nous regardions des
double caméra vidéo ça m'a régalé c'est
quoi ça m'a donné envie de recharger la
batterie de la mienne et de la réactiver
après je vous cache pas il se passe pas
grand chose quoi vraiment tout ce que je
vois c'est des livreurs qui sonne et qui
espère que j'ouvre rapidement pour
continuer leurs troupes face à un peu
déprimant en fait moi ce qui se passe
chez alice je suis un peu con quoi d'en
avoir mis une sur un palier d'immeubles
c'est idiot de fou si vous espérez que
des trucs comme ce qu'on vient de voir
vous arrive ça n'arrivera pas ça pour
dire que j'ai bien profité de cette
vidéo la tournée tranquille chez moi
dans ma zone de confort allez ciao
cliquez sur notre vidéo du valais
[Musique]
non